memes
they are the cultural lifeblood of
esports and twitch chat is sort of like
their circulatory system
there have been moments that have
created memes that endure even to this
day
mostly because well they're pretty dank
for this list
the meme moment has to have some
meaningful connection to an esports
title
but beyond that we're just ranking them
based on how much we enjoy them
and how usable they are either in twitch
chat or in real life
buckle up things are about to get pretty
dank
coming in at number 10 is one of the
finest memes in casting history
lecod matata
during a group stage match between
fnatic and team secret at esl one
katowice 2018
fnatic managed to turn around a losing
team fight
but everyone's attention was on a call
from the filipino casters
lon and dunno
means to walk strongly or like a boss
while normally
refers to auto attacks sprinkled
throughout were some other great lines
that were not only
funny but they were also just extremely
exploitable
gaben welcomed ti attendees using the
phrase
valve took notice adding the voice lines
as chat wheel options in the game
and og would go on to use them to troll
constantly at ti-8
where they won it all they're gonna go
for another set of racks
both caused down no buyback on samayal
no buyback on rtz
taking our number nine spot is the most
famous face
in esports history this one wow
can you say gg even top players get
outplayed sometimes
but their reactions to those moments can
be equally as entertaining it's why many
players choose to keep their faces
as emotionless as possible during
competition
but sometimes you get dunked thinker
what was that baker with a ui play the
qss
i guess i actually want that duel
i can't point this telecon
let's be honest this particular outplay
didn't matter to the outcome of the
match
but to esports as a whole well we
wouldn't be spamming that disappointed
face in chat when ryu dies
if it had never happened
our eighth entry is the only russian
phrase that most esports players know
many games don't have dedicated russian
servers but
most have voice chat so this common
russian expletive has become a rallying
cry of sorts
especially in cs it's definitely a
weapon you can work well with and as you
pointed out
he is a specialist on it there's a
couple of them out there
great t-shirts an exact translation
isn't really necessary
it's used as an expression of
frustration and counter-strike helped to
popularize it
making it the rallying cry of anyone
who's getting a little pissed off
it's even been chanted by the crowd at
counter-strike
events
that's a new one
[Applause]
you know what they're saying
[Applause]
at number seven is a man who has
basically become the patron saint of pc
gaming
gaben hi my name is gabe newell and i
work at valve
gabe newell isn't just an executive he's
a living legend
he co-founded valve software responsible
for some of pc gaming's greatest hits
but he's also clearly a gamer and when a
voice clip in a team fortress 2
commentary mode had him say his email
address aloud
it provided his new alter ego gaben
please let me know what you think after
you have had a chance to play
i can be reached at gaben at
valvesoftware.com
since that time gaben has become a near
holy figure online
he blesses us with steam sales he
determines
who gets the knife from the crates he's
like a dank
beardless santa claus basically
and he even voiced an announcer pack for
dota 2.
hello i'm gabe newell you've just
achieved first blood
thanks and have fun basically praise
lord gaben when you
have to gloat about someone getting
baited into a very stupid move
there's nothing better than the debated
emote a gleeful picture of tournament
organizer alex jabali's face jabali used
to unmap a button on his fight stick and
smash it loudly
to bait or confuse his opponent leading
to the debated name
fell for the oldest trigger that's the
one donation from jenna tools oh no no
no you just did it
but the emote is actually far older than
you might believe
with the first version depicting a
jabali macho man randy savage hybrid
eventually it was changed to a picture
of jabeli's face
from ceo 2016 and a copy pasta using the
emote
became extremely popular during law
worlds
exposing a greater audience to jubated
maybe with the 45 seconds on baron
oh that's the ultimate though
oh no he doesn't get knocked up gertie's
done nobody's taking down the cap he
gets out of the way with the rest of my
daddy they're in trouble
that's the guardian
number five it's three two two the
ultimate reaction for when players put
up a
suspiciously terrible performance it was
already very low to begin with three
seconds
solo as well they just went in here
today what's up with that
that's not good the meme began after
alexei
solo barrazin threw a game for 322
dollars in skins
i don't want to say it's impossible for
us to come back but you'll oh he's so
dead
why is he standing here i don't know
rough
that's rough i mean skeleton king has
had a difficult game four ten
and four it was the first high-profile
match fixing case in dota 2
and after reports surfaced solo
eventually admitted
he had bet 100 and received 322.
the final punishment he received was
light little more than a slap on the
wrist
but valve made it clear afterward that
future infractions like this from any
player
would be far more severe now you see it
any time someone does something
so stupid that it looks like they must
be throwing
to earn a little skin money wants to
jump on the shield
about the brain we need to keep it so
close there's the shield damage jump
forward
hp and the cat well there's one of his
nine lives
you probably know summit 1g from twitch
where he's one of the biggest streamers
on the platform but he's also the reason
that we all spam
1g anytime someone self-emulates
oh my goodness there's that
oh summit what's up reddit
you had it playing as a stand-in for
splice at dreamhack austin 2016
summit managed to kill fugly but before
he could defuse the bomb
he melted his own ankles off
and slice will close out map number one
sixteen to eleven
oh wait what
what happened oh no
summit no
oh that is uh heartbreaking the round
would have given splice the map win
instead they ended up losing it in
overtime
embarrassing moments make for great meme
fodder sure
it's pretty rare in competitive cs go
that a player burns themselves to death
but that just makes it more satisfying
to spam 1g
when it does molotov gets skadoodle and
locked him into the tree couldn't
extinguish he couldn't get away it was
going to get stewie with the same
summit buddy how you doing stewie says
hello
valve anti-cheat has a checkered past
and the memes
it has inspired come in at number three
on our list
angry ninjas in his face very soon
oh that is fast
put that in your pipe and smoke it there
was a time when vac was considered
nearly toothless
but in 2014 a series of high-profile vac
bans
shook the cs go competitive community
some even happening
mid competition did emilio just get back
banned
we'll assume that that's like some sort
of error for now until we get any other
confirmation
if 322 is what you spam when someone is
playing poorly
vac is the go-to when someone is playing
well
a little too well insane flick
back so he should just be able to free
run with the awp and there we go
flicking away make that four can he get
the fifth as well
wall someone or spam through smoke vac
what is that and if we're wrong about
the whole hacking thing
well being accused of cheating is
basically a compliment anyways right
now this round is back oh no what the
hell was that
[ __ ] what around the
i can't even speak i'm done
our runner-up spot goes to rainbow six
siege's one
true god lord tachanka oh
oh he flipped the helmet my
[Laughter]
in siege speed and precision count for a
lot so it seems strange to put an
operator in the game whose entire shtick
was to slowly set up a very loud
and immobile lmg he just didn't fit the
game's pace at all
and in fact was so bad that he became a
meme unto himself
if you have an ace with the tachanka
then chances are you're gonna be number
one because
all hell lord chanka the ironic lord
tachanka
quickly picked up steen the rework
didn't really help him that much
he has another one coming up but at this
point it's pretty difficult to imagine
him being any good
little bit he's like we're surely gonna
okay we're going to say to chiang
castratas i'm sure you've got plenty of
information about those in your pocket
so i'll let you talk to them sorry mate
all the research i've done
me on my need praying to the lord no
matter what happens
the siege community has welcomed the
lord into their hearts
at the top of our list is an emote that
perfectly captures
why we love competitive gaming at all
hey where's my peppa guy now boys
all i see is a poggy pog poggy pogba we
live for the incredible moments that
seem impossible
and that we know we'll never forget the
face we now know as pogchamp
belongs to ryan goutex gutierrez and the
event that caused it
is honestly pretty mundane okay
oh i'm sorry now let's go let's go to
the cloud in a blooper reel for cross
counter tv
gutex reacted to someone bumping the
camera and the expression you know and
love
was born but it didn't come to be
associated with the pog champ name
until later after gutex and fellow socal
fighting games player
mike ross did a promo from mad cat fight
stick
that involved pogs neato gutex
pogs let's play micros the eventual
emote like the expression blends
surprise but also hype if someone makes
a great play
hands out a sick burn or something
unexpected happens
you can be sure to find some pog champs
in the chat
alright so that's our list there's
plenty of dank meme moments in esports
it was hard enough to contain this list
to only 10. what was your favorite that
we missed
let us know in the comments below hit
the like and subscribe button
and stay tight and stay tight and
we'll see you soon well
they're pretty dank
well mostly because they're pretty dank
because well they're pretty dank
there have been moments that created
memes that endure
even to this day [ __ ]